bello a tutti ragazzi è bene non deve
solo video sonova vj e questa è la mia
smart c'è nel senso che lo parcheggiata
qua è [ __ ] quelle invece quello che
vedete vi sfondo mio marone il mio
marone destro dubbi ragazzi sensu rocket
league che un gioco tipo è un gioco tipo
di calcio più o meno voglio provare a
giocarla adesso per per vedere se sono
ancora bravo come un tempo però io lo
avevo giocato tempo fa tra l'altro dato
sto giocando online un lungo e si chiama
james leggings sarà un attore di
hollywood
la prima si riesca a giocare uguale tipo
come quando giocavo da piccolo ma meno
succhia parigi ha segnato 10 zio
qualcuno lo prende al culo oggi mi
spiace che questo quando sto giocando ha
comprato adesso mi sa pero e mi dispiace
se ho vinto io è quando giochi contro
inabili il problema è che io giocavo a
questo gioco sei anni fa che era la
stessa cosa e quindi so giocare anche se
non ci ho mai giocato quindi in poche
parole sto [ __ ] ha già perso appello
nel si ma lo sai che la porta mia sta
dall'altra parte che cazzo stai a
giocare così ho preso palo sparando come
se fosse mia nonna ma vabbè cast che
assiste grassi si guarda lo guarda lo
guardo bello anch'io ci ammira mi dicono
aspetta fermo fermo fermo
[Applauso]
ho fatto cinque gol in 45 secondi
ragazzi abbandonare la partita
facciamo un doppio va ci siamo ragazzi
siamo contro zach harum mans box che
sbocca per terra ce la possiamo fare
tutta la mia propaggini insieme
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cazzo preso il palo non ci credo mai by
zack harum che gol che col 10 ragazzi
basta non troppo bravi non so perché ho
giocato per tipo 2 anni di fila quindi
[ __ ] bravo bravo fa vj che ci
gioca due anni di fila non sa ma come si
tocca la palla bravo bravo una uno che
figura di merda come non detto ragazzi
stavo scherzando tutta la brutta brutta
butta la butta la bravo zio ma dove
anche lager
vai che sei il mio meglio segno ma il
disegno [ __ ] che mira di merda già
ma dai
bravo bravissimo
che grande che cazzo di gol ho fatto
lega ma veramente nice sta minkia lega
mak mais ma solo nice mi dici ma
[ __ ]
siamo tre a tre ragazzi manca un minuto
e mezzo possiamo vincere lo so
bastardi dai ma perché primo top mi
hanno smaterializzato a cazzo
non ci credo ma come ma cavolo fatta
mancarla ma dai non ci voglio mai come
ho fatta mancare la lega c'e vabbè bravo
stai facendo il video bravo e il gol
della vittoria ragazzi lo segna fa vj
come se non ci fosse un domani ma perché
io allora dovete capire che io io e
lionel messi valutiamo la sera quindi
più o meno io ho assorbito le sue
capacità artistiche sono riuscito a
vincere non fatemi domande non so come
non ne ho la più pallida idea ho fatto
il gol della vittoria 43 essa lo
ficcavano al culo per ragazzi proviamo
l'ultima in assoluto per vedere se
riusciamo se non col cazzo davo il
rimbalzo è giusto e rega in base giusto
lo vedete questo proprio dalla base alla
punta tutto nel culo tutto voglio la
vittoria mi ha succhiato si chiamano
l'incazzatura che prende il sopravvento
e dai 2 0 2 a 0 forza che abbiamo solo
iniziato anzi voglio la vittoria
schiacciante con un piangere mandare
dalla mamma e dire mamma mi ha battuto
fa vj piango la voci o che gol che fai
tutta la puntata butta in mezzo ma
qualche figlio di puca che cosa che ho
fatto non ho mai visto neanche visto con
un senatore che ho segnato ma non so
come hanno giocato a che non ho neanche
visto mi sono smaterializzato subito
tripletta e non vorrei dire ragazzi ma
tripletta non vorrei dire bravo
cannavaro lo butta e mezzo incredibile a
butta lì assist ed è gol
sono quattro e sono 4 in una partita
sola falso rivi la palla in mezzo
incredibile arriva fa vj arriva vj porca
[ __ ] perfetto come l'ho tolta come
l'ho tolta perché non gli muore la
famiglia perché ho segnato ho segnato
veramente io rega ci ho fatto gol senza
voleva [ __ ] perfetto perfetto
grande bravissimo senza pro aggi nei
ragazzi tanto propaggini in un giocatore
so
maradona mi fa una pippa dai queste cose
dai che queste cose che queste gol 6 a 2
io e zaccaro io non so chi cazzo si
attaccano ma domani io voglio incontrare
io voglio offrire una birra che facciamo
un altro gol da che facciamo un altro
gol prima che scada il tempo ma non è
finita finita cazzo sto segnando ma
vaffan cuore va dai 6 a 2 e mi
accontento 6 a 2
55 gol in una partita cinque gol gol ho
fatto gol io ho fatto con il vero
problema ragazzi che questa era la mia
porta dovevo far gol dall'altra parte
però va bene mamma
che gol magari ma [ __ ] che mira che
mira incredibile ciao ragazzi per la
porta incredibile forza volta a porta
vuota ragazzo ma chi è fuori il j
assegnato siamo 3 a 1 e mi sa che è
finita quando non è finita qua perché
manca tipo mezz'ora buttano in mezzo
bravo zaccaro un bravo hai fatto il
video bravo guardai che hanno segnato si
gol gol 4 1 4 1 stiamo vincendo siamo o
un anno le famiglie
no figlio di [ __ ] segnato col fato
avevo giocato ed move sony ma va ma vaff
inchieste che botta aiutato vai vai al
ai bigonci co2 magari chiusi o distratto
completamente un avversario mentre ha
segnato perfetto finita è finita finita
e abbiamo vinto il cinque a due ragazzi
ho fatto un gol sono ma ne è valsa la
pena che bello sto campo sembra tipo più
reale tipo erbaceo bravo perfetto mai
una volta che riesco a fare gol
all'inizio cazzo
dai che vinca sarà giusto merda dai luci
credo mi stavo pensando di brutto cazzo
ma è così
così se come noi ma ma l'ho fatto io sto
ma [ __ ]
per una volta che segno io mi dovete
deve dare il gol a lui guarda a come lui
vabbè vabbè macchia ma vai a cagare va
capito siamo il palleggio e palleggio e
palleggio pellè pelè assist dove sono
buttarla dentro zio manco quello se
riuscito a fare mi chiamo fa tutto io
almeno quello ton e mezzo buttare in
mezzo time eto'o bravo bravissimo ed è
gol
ed è gol fa vj la butta dentro manco
fosse cristiano ronaldo lega guardalo li
guardi come arriva tutto tutto coatto
bravissimo mamma mia non è gol
mica ho preso palo
e poi c'è il conto che anche meno male
che c'era lui perché potevo chris
tornare in svedese buttare nei messo una
volta sola nella vita fallo fallo ti
prego ti prego ti supplico madonna che
lento bravo zio non ci arrivo non ci
arriva un ci arrivo è arrivato a tua
madre però una volta che ero convinto di
arrivo
chi è che mi ha fatto esplodere bastardi
che gol è un aspetto svegliato porta era
l'altra se ho fatto l'assist ho segnato
nella mia [ __ ] porta geniale no
passardi si gol perfetto mai così ma è
così 41 ho recuperato lallero lancio di
prima perfetto clap clap clap a na sega
non cup sori di lol dai rassegnato
nessuno bruci credo voi come come
abbiamo fatto
non ci voglio mai credere nella vita non
è possibile toscano si toscano zero come
lavoravo alla gola annuncia volta volta
perfetto credo che abbia capito
paolo ha preso paolo ha preso paro
ragazzi non abbiamo perso
non so come abbia vinto 4 a 3 ho avuto
un ansia che non avete idea ragazzi
il piano cristiano ronaldo ancora lui
cristiano cristiano che tocco di merda
cristiano cristiano cristiano ma
[ __ ] dai bravo bravo bravo
qualcosa ma scorsa ma come ma non ci
credo mai
guarda lo guarda non l'ho tolta io
centriste ma cos'è tua madre trovato la
palla affanculo vecchi gol e che gol e
che gol
scusa ma chi cazzo me l'ha tolto non ci
credo l'abbiamo persa una
uno a zero come avrà fatto a perdere 10
perché abbiamo sfiorato il limite della
pro hugin e acuta per i ragazzi è stato
rocket league
questa è veramente fantastico cioè
l'anno migliorato il gioco che avevo
giocato io credo che ha un nome piccolo
si chiamava supersoniche acrobatic
rocket power and butter cars è un nome
proprio leggere ovunque con quello che
l'episodio perché la propaggine si sta
facendo troppo però che vi sia piaciuto
spero che abbiate una patente perché
sennò perché sennò guido io e quindi
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto quanto
incassato momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come nei video
trovata nella descrizione se non se lo
angoli cities cretini cv diavolo
prossimo video della ragazza